let f of X be equal to one-half X to the
third plus three X minus four let H be
the inverse of F notice that F of
negative two is equal to negative 14 and
then they're asking us what is H prime
of negative 14 and if you're not
familiar with the how functions and
their derivatives relate to their
inverses and the derivatives of the
inverse well this will seem like a very
hard thing to do because if you're
attempting to take the inverse of F to
figure out what H is well it's tough to
find to take to figure out the inverse
of a third degree a third degree
polynomial defined function like this so
the key the key I guess property to
realize or the key truth to realize if
that if if F and H are inverses then H
prime of X H prime of X is going to be
equal to
it's going to be equal to 1 over F prime
of H of X 1 over F prime of H of X and
you could now use this in order to
figure out what H prime of negative 14
is now I know what some of you are
thinking because it's exactly what I
would be thinking if someone just sprung
this on me is where does this come from
and I would tell you this comes straight
out of the chain rule we know that if a
funk funk ssin and it's inverse we know
that if we have a function in its
inverse that f of f of the inverse of
our function so f of h of x f of h of x
we know that this is going to be equal
to x this literally this is comes out of
them being each other's inverses we
could have also said H of f of X will
also be equal to X remember F is going
to map or H is going to map from some X
to H of X and then F is going to map
back to that original X that's what
inverses do so that's because they are
inverses this is by definition this is
what inverses do to each other but then
if you took the derivative of both sides
of this what would you get let me do
that so if we take the derivative of
both sides of this d DX on the left hand
side d DX on the right
hand side I think you see where this is
going you're essentially going to get a
version of that the left-hand side use
the chain rule you're going to get F
prime of H of X F prime of H of x times
H prime of X comes straight out of the
chain rule is equal to is equal to the
derivative of X is just going to be
equal to 1 and then you derive you
divide both sides by F prime of H of X
and you get our original property there
so now with that out of the way let's
just actually apply this so we want to
evaluate H prime of 14-4 sorry H prime
of negative 14 is going to be equal to 1
over F prime of H of negative 14 H of
negative 14 now have they given us H of
negative 14 well they didn't give it to
us explicitly but we have to remember
that F and H are inverses of each other
so if F of negative 2 is negative 14
well H is going to go from the other way
around if you input negative 14 into H
you're going to get negative 2 so H of
negative 14 well this is going to be
equal to negative 2 once again they are
inverses of each other
so H of negative 14 is equal to negative
negative 2 and once again I just swapped
these two around that's what the inverse
function will do if you're mapping from
if f goes from negative 2 to negative 14
H is going to go from negative 14 back
to negative 2 so now we want to evaluate
F prime of negative 2 well let's let's
figure out what f prime of X is so f
prime of X is equal to C which can
leverage the power rule so 3 times 1/2
is 3 halves times X to the 3 minus 1
power which is just the second power
plus the derivative of 3x with respect
to X well that's just going to be 3 and
you could view that it's just the power
rule if this was X to the first power 1
times 3x to the zeroth power well X to
the 0 is just 1 so you just left with 3
and derivative a constant that's just
going to be 0 so that's F prime of X so
f prime
time of f prime of negative two is going
to be three-halves times negative two
squared is four positive 4 so plus three
so this is going to be equal to 2 times
3 plus 3 so 6 plus 3 is equal to 9 so
this denominator right here is going to
be equal to 9 so this whole thing is
equal to 1 over 9
so this involved this was a just you
know this isn't something you're you're
going to see every day this isn't a
typical problem in your calculus class
but it's it's interesting